Good morning, Hank. It's Tuesday.
Today's video is like Plato's understanding of the human soul: It comes to you in three parts.
Part one: the small matter of giving away more than a million dollars
So, Hank, the 2015 Project for Awesome raised more than 1.5 million dollars, total.
We don't know the final shipping costs for the perks, yet.
so, I can't give out final numbers. But today, I do get to announce the winning charities.
Hank, I don't even know how to communicate my excitement about how well
the Project for Awesome went this year.
Except to say that I am like Cheez-Doodles-guy excited about it.
Ya! Yaaaaaaa! YeaaaaaAAH!
God, I love Cheez Doodles guy!
So, during the first half of Project for Awesome, we raised more than a million dollars,
with the help of some matching donors to be split between
Save the Children and the UN's Refugee Agency
and, then, all the money raised during the second half of Project for Awesome goes to charities
chosen by the Nerdfighter community via voting at projectforawesome.com
So, the following ten charities got the most votes and will each receive 25 thousand dollar grants:
NaNoWriMo, which encourages creative writing and gives writing resources to schools and libraries;
The Against Malaria Foundation;
The Harry Potter Alliance, which turns fandoms toward activism;
This Star Won't Go Out, which provides direct support to families
who have a kid with cancer or another serious illness;
Liberty in North Korea, which assists North Korean Refugees and
fights to expose the Human Rights abuses there;
water.org which provides sustainable clean water solutions to people around the world;
She's the First, which provides educational oppurtunities to girls in the developing world;
Planned Parenthood, which provides healthcare to women the United States
and, Action Against Hunger, which works to end hunger and malnutrition worldwide.
And, then, Hank, the next ten most voted charities will receive smaller grants
but still more than ten thousand dollars.
Those include: lava mae, Doctors without Borders, The Malala Fund, Uplift,
Direct, Relief, Not Forgotten, the Great Ormond Street Children's Hospital,
Soap Aid, charity: water,  and the American Foundation for Suicide Prevention.
So, that's all where the money is going, thank you for donating,
again, all the charities were decided by your votes at projectforawesome.com. So, thanks for voting.
Also, you can find more info about the charities in doobly-doo below
including a playlist with Project for Awesome videos about each of them.
Part 2: Hank, our mom's artist friend, Connie Bostic, has made the greatest New Year's card of all time
and I wanted to share it with you. It's called
"We Must Live In Joy Through the Sorrows of this World."
No real story there. Just a great New Year's card.
Part 3: Hank, as this is my final vlogbrothers video of 2015
I must ask nerdfighteria four very important questions, to be addressed in the comments below:
1) What would you like to see more and/or less of, on vlogbrothers next year?
2) Should the rules change? 3) Should the schedule change?
And, 4) are you seriously going to punish me because my video about refugee camps
in Ethiopia was longer than four minutes, you horrible, hideous monsters?
I tried really hard to frame that question in a non-partisan way. I think I pulled it off.
Hank, I am off to go play FIFA as the AFC Wimbledon Wimbly-Womblies.
You can find that over at youtube.com/hankgames, where Hank doesn't play games.
Happy New Year! Hank! I will see you on Friday.